cute too I hate it
Brent what is this let's go what is
going on here what are these dudes this
is a book series for my childhood called
Animorphs I was obsessed with it as a
kid and I'm now rereading the series as
an adult even if you've never read the
book I feel like everyone is at least
familiar with these book covers they're
iconic it's a classic morphing effect
where you basically start out with one
image and you're trying to go to a
second image what is that that's not an
animal he's an alien called an andalite
so you get to turn a day no no he is an
alien and he's turning into a boy
looking good
this is so amazing just from the covers
alone and
cool because it was like it didn't talk
down to kids and it dealt with like
really dark issues and it was a really
cool introduction to more complex
thought there's a television show yes
there was a television show that ran for
a little while in the late 90s like 98
to 99. it was okay each morph took six
weeks to make
wow well you've been looking into how to
do these morph effects yourself yes so I
made something
in the middle dude
[Music]
[Applause]
this program it's basically an Animorphs
plug-in I animated the mask at the same
point on the Frog now I obviously I did
this in like an hour maybe an hour and a
half compared to the six weeks it
originally took to do the whole thing
but I I can't help but feel like there's
a more elevated level of this like
what's the what's the level three
version of this level one right hearing
run talk about Animorphs give me an idea
we can make his dreams come true I
wouldn't even be that hard we gotta get
Dean on this
I think
so loud
you don't think it's a little like
cursed though no it's not like I mean
come true it's shocking but it's like a
shocking in a way that when you receive
a gift on Christmas or something like
that it's gonna change his life what's
going on guys nothing important for you
plutonic things between
meetings just close this right now the
question is though like what animal
would it be because like it's got to be
his soul animal bird we're gonna turn
right into a bird bird
up
the first part of this is the classic
animorph oh there he goes
first you grab a photo scan and then I
just went on CG Trader and grabbed a
random Bird model generic bird and using
blender sculpt tools you just shift
their butt into the shape of an animal
so then I make two renders I make one of
Ren turning into a weird up
animal and then I render out the animal
turning into a weird up Wren and
basically Crossfade between the two
renders and that's how you make a 3D
animorph that's fun but I realize it's
much better when you turn off the bird
wow I've never seen Animorphs like this
before
Maybe This Is It
Ren we read through the subtext of our
last conversation and we have a gift
you saw the joy the light on Ren's face
he loved it everybody loved it joy joy
in his eyeballs almost probably do you
think we could do that for the rest of
the office
like I mean that elicits the question
though
what is each person's spirit animal
let's start with our lovely Founders
here yeah let's start at the top Sam
gorse
is there a strong Beast that Sam could
embody yeah orangutan
I see it with the beard and this cheek
flap Sam is an orangutan let's move on
Nico's the other one I already know this
one Nico's don't worry
wow Minx is pretty good you get too
close like that energy inside he's got
that energy if he has the passion he's
dangerous right no no physical way he
doesn't hurt us here anymore koala bear
Henley with koala up there come on
liking it yeah oh and he gets new
fingers oh and he gets new fingers look
at his hands got a split in half the
nose is gonna get real Nico is a koala
bear moving on he did the very obvious
one for Ren we did his name is literally
a bird so who is who's Wren actually
Bren is a cat a cat and a cat no wren's
not a cat gotta get outside the
mammalian King yeah let's get out of it
and the mammals he needs a shell on him
at all times for protection
he's always doing
can you give me like um Rango chameleons
that's done and he eats everything Ren
is a chameleon moving on I feel like
Nick is a shrimp he's a shrimp yeah he's
a shrimp the shrimp dude that's got it
what am I even thinking Nick is a shrimp
moving on all right who else we got
Jordan Coleman she's more of like a bear
you know they look sweet and cuddly and
stuff but then
the correct answer is snapping turtle
she's stubborn stubborn and just bitter
look at the bitter yeah I love it all
right so we did all these people but now
we have to do ourselves I'll step out I
trust you this is a lot of
responsibility this guy
I'm a comedian I'm so funny
what's going on with him I can't hear
what you're saying but I hear the tone
Oh and I don't like it okay you cut it
out
[Music]
you feel good about it oh I feel real
good will I feel good about it I'm out
please just consideration
otters
I was gonna do a hunter but now I said
it I feel like he kind of Tainted him he
tasted it utterly doesn't work
wait he's from Florida animals
[Music]
better not be
man get out of it I lived in Florida for
a section of my childhood and so one
thing we had was manatees Matt a tea
Matt a tea That's it are you freaking
serious as Matt we haven't had anybody
put on some Mass it's important to pack
on mass you thinks he's an otter but
he's really a manatee and that's so
Manatee to think you're an otter huh
yeah that's everybody's spirit animal I
think all we need is photo scans of all
of them it's more fun more fun three one
two three
[Music]
hey can we photo scan you what are they
gonna do to me you can trust us we're
gonna do anything weird we need her
mouth open right oh yeah without looking
terrified don't look terrified she has
no just know who we're planning for her
and that's the best part
we got the photo scans
It's morphin time It's morphin time
Dean I wanted to do it
[Applause]
oh
my gosh Dean come here
oh that's creepy I have now added face
bones each of those bones capture a
piece of that geometry so that it'll
move when the bone moves I think the
best thing that we could do is scrinch
and Pull and slide him into the shape of
the animal and then I'm going to take
them in blender and sculpt the mesh of
the photo scans even further because
these Transformations are going to be
horrific your face is getting torn apart
as you can see here with Matt like this
is exactly what you want dude don't look
at this stop this is not this is private
this is private don't look at this we'll
see this later so I think what might
Elevate this even more is if on the
front end we have like a miximo
stationary animation he's going to be
begging and then the transformation
while they're up there making their
surprise Animorphs I got a surprise for
them it's the secret ingredient that
really will make these anamorphs shine
sound I can't give you exactly what your
animal is okay it's a mystery but just
think big guy it's a little fry
[Music]
that's pretty good think about an animal
that's got a real bite to it
[Music]
nail it
it's literally the weekend my wife is at
home and yet here I sit lurking over
Dean's shoulder watching him mold this
turd tail I'm an artist you really are
you've done something great here look at
this beady eyes dude
I'm losing my mind
uh who am I I look back on previous
videos and I hardly recognize myself
anymore I don't know who I am or what
I'm turning into but the morph is
underway but it's okay because it's for
the greater good all right this is for
our friends we're gonna we're gonna put
a smile on their face when they see
themselves manifested as the animals
that they were born to be I think it's
going to do a whole deal of good for the
studio so I don't mind staying here over
the weekend to work on this because
every project I do inside blender I feel
like it inches me more and more towards
the goal being a better visual effects
artist I feel like the sculpting kind of
brings it over the top because I think
this is what elevates this to being art
wow
this is special man we're doing
something special this is something
important
each and every one of you have a beast
inside we want to bring that Beast out
but each and every one of you have a
different Beast inside of you when you
were at the book fair you know in
elementary school and you saw an
Animorphs on the Shelf what did you
imagine your animorph would be I had a
horseshoe crab really like a praying
mantis I have always related to a sea
turtle you do have a turtle like Glide
to you thank you I always thought that
too all right first up is Jordan Coleman
oh
yes you are
dead
yes dude
that's this is for genuine Joy this is
what this does do you see Joy where is
the turtle texture the animal's still
inside you and don't you see everyone's
favorite part of the animorph is the
in-between where you can still see the
little human child peeking out it's just
the middle we're removing the animal
just the morph dude just the morph yeah
I'm just filled with joy I mean I love
Turtles I am a turtle I'm not a snapping
turtle in my in my own fantasy is it
because I get Snappy yeah she pretty
much nailed it yeah I'm happy next up is
Matt
[Music]
what's the eyes
the eyes it kind of looks like Drake
yeah
it's the rudest thing I've ever heard as
a Florida man this speaks to my soul a
manatee-sized amount of Joy Sam that's
your time all right
this is gonna be sweet
oh
what's up baboon
it's just that weird bulbous thing
around my face
like how are you doing this this is so
weird Sam do you feel seen with this
piece
Ren is up next I am up next
that is so nice
oh
yeah dude I got a ridgeback spine all
right what sound is that
[Music]
looking technology next up next getting
nervous dude I'm nervous I don't really
know what to expect here I think I know
exactly what to expect Nico we've proven
in the past that this technology does
not exist to make human shrimp hybrids
it doesn't exist for years I've been
thinking about this and I've even tried
it you know in a couple experiments and
I never can get there I think you'll be
very pleased
[Music]
no way
[Applause]
under the pan
that's good man dude you didn't know it
was possible did you do this dude dude I
did this for you
my eyes are sweaty right now thank you I
feel seen as F right now dude
you'll see let me get that three month
personal use please Nico
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
I love how tight those eyelids are man
they have sort of like a rectal blink to
them like
some girls look at the joy how would you
characterize the amount of joy in your
heart
um
you know the amount of joy of my heart
and to conclude here uh Jordan and I
were working together on this but I had
to do his in private so that he couldn't
see it
so uh all right let's take it home
[Music]
wow Dean
what did you do
this is amazing what did you do
what did you do dude
oh
no the skins
foreign
[Applause]
wow
bring it in you've given me such a gift
you know I gotta say of all the morphs
I've seen this week watching Dean
transform from Editor to VFX artist has
brought me the most Joy it's a beautiful
thing gosh Dean you've truly grown as an
artist so much
static I feel seen I feel heard this is
one of the greatest moments of my life
it's honestly it's art Dean it's art
change can hurt but once we embrace it
we find ourselves at home
[Music]
foreign